like what the actual percentages of men
that make over a certain amount but so
do you think
do you think you're in the top 20
percent of females
to get that
top 20 innocent one financially no just
like in what men value which is like
femininity beauty it starts with looks
femininity beauty do you think you're in
the top 20 of females no
so then if if
i then you probably would be dating a
gut be dating a guy that makes less
do you think it'd be a problem if you
couldn't submit to a guy that dates less
do you think that would cause issues in
a relationship
it would yeah i'm just talking from
experience from what i've observed from
other people's marriages
yeah yeah what do you think
yeah i think it most likely would yeah
it would yeah
um
so what's the question
so since since
let's say
20 of men make over that yeah
um which is just going to fact check
because i wasn't sure but
do you think you're in the top 20 of
females
i'd like to believe so but um
i don't know why not i think so maybe
top 20 of females
i mean it would it help if you had some
females that are in the top 20 that you
could give examples so that they can
okay okay okay so um i mean kevin
samuels always says beyonce is an eight
okay so do you think you're as pretty as
beyonce no
well kelly ross i don't really think
beyonce is that pretty in all honesty or
rihanna so um
i think rihanna's prettier yeah um
yeah i mean but would you say you're in
that if i had enough money as rihanna
yeah i think i could be
because she they all have money so money
makes you look better like if they were
normal people no no it starts with it
they're very like big ladies with money
they're there
oprah for example i think money helps
optimize what's there yeah yeah that's
what i mean yeah that's fine
but i was going to say like
is it being fit and it's outfit feminine
and friendly yeah i have all that but
i'm not fit yet i'm working towards it
and it goes by facial symmetry so the
way i look at it is like
most people are average right so i do
four like and i kind of take it i'm
gonna give credit cause i know in the
comments they'll be like credit kevin
samuels yeah yeah
i know i know i know i always think of
like eight is the prettiest girl in the
small town nine means you make it to
hollywood based on your looks 10 is damn
near perfect so nines and tens they'll
make it to hollywood aids is the
prettiest girl in a small town i don't
really give out like sevens because you
have to pick are you are you beautiful
gorgeous are you cute
and and so most people are four fives
and sixes they're pretty you're cute
yeah i'm average i think
okay yeah i'd definitely say i'm like an
average four maybe or something yeah
okay
um
that's that's humble like that's i get
credit just facts i mean a lot of girls
a lot of girls come on and say ten so
go ahead you know i wouldn't say i'm a
10 but i don't necessarily think i'm
average maybe just a bit
beyond that like like six yeah okay okay
six
but like i this is just a common problem
that i see in relationships is like
as
average girls we want above average guys
and then we can't submit to the guys
that are at our level
he just jumped
yeah these are because like average is
35 000 that's the average income in
london
or it might be 45 but we said up to 70
we said up to 70 to fully commit which
is i'm not knocking you for it i think a
lot of people would say the same things
i guess when you say fully commit for us
it submits yeah submit is like you've
given
all yourself away yeah so it's like it's
i guess it's a hard thing to grasp
because i guess we live in an
environment where that's not taught or
not really yeah yeah
well it's like there can't be two there
can't be two ceos in a house someone has
to lead yeah have you ever been in a
relationship where you had felt like you
had to lead yeah yeah and i had to end
those like take any you take initiative
for goodness sake yeah what do you yeah
same it just
it just feels like you're the man yeah
yeah it's very uncomfortable yeah it
does not feel you don't feel safe yeah
yeah
oh the same
yeah and i'm curious from the guys have
you ever had experiences where the women
like tried to lead
in this country yeah
yeah i mean um it's
you get you got a lot of women who have
a very strong male energy and they want
to lead even in dancing yeah we're doing
salsa i'm like love
i'm i have to do this
hold on
and they're like trying to make moves
i'm like no this this was a reflection
of the relationship
where they were constantly i'm like look
i'll make this decision i'll make this
call how about next time you make the
call and then and so on we're talking
small things like one time
we went into a bar and um
i made the decision of the drinks well i
mean i didn't make the decision i'm like
you're drinking this i said this is a
really nice drink
i drink it all the time would you like
to try it and she liked that but
then again other times it was always
like a little bit of pushback on on
things that i said look i know what well
what i'm doing here it's okay i got this
but it was a constant
you know push and pull and that's i
think it is because of women have very
strong you know some women have very
strong male energy
it's very nice because with the
submission thing like the intangible
things that i look for is can you take
initiative for me i find it hard to find
a guy who wants to take initiative you
asked me out and then you asked me to
plan the date like no [ __ ] no
no bye
i'm not doing that
like i've dealt a couple of um girls who
maybe you know maybe try to take leading
certain things or whatever
and it's weird and this is some game for
the guys
um i said to one of my friends he was
considering buying his first place with
his girlfriend i said don't do it
yeah i was like your first place as a
man should be yours and i'll give you
this story as to why
there was a girl who was dating at one
point where
she stayed with me for like a couple of
weeks and i owned my own home and stuff
and
when she was staying she was trying to
make certain decisions for the household
and then it was like we went away on
holiday and stuff and we drove you know
in my car and everything
and there was certain decisions she was
trying to make and i was like you know
i'm a i'm a nice guy like i'm reasonable
do you know what i mean but then it did
get to a point where i had to be like
you're in my house
this is my house everything i've sorted
for us i've done for us
right so if i'm not okay with something
it's not happening i wouldn't be able to
do that
if
there was
co-ownership
and it's not about necessarily having
control but i think as as a man part of
the when we say authority
it's almost like
you almost have to have that authority
on paper because you don't want to have
to play that card
if someone's trying to violate you
but you can play it if you need to does
that make sense so it's one of those
things where it's like
that's the only time where
i realized that
if i wasn't in that position
then there could have been even more of
a clash but it was like you know i was
like look with audrey swear like this is
my place like what kind of things was
she doing she wanted to like move some
furniture around she wanted to like i'm
thinking you've been here a week like
um
was like you know saying she was saying
stuff about
how
uh
something about how oh she was like
wanting to cook and stuff and she was
sending out that i didn't offer and the
reason i didn't offer because i had a
session with a client
and she was saying ah you've not helped
in this i was like i'm sorry who got us
here who
booked the hotel who did this this this
and this
and like when it's logistically true
like you can't argue with that so i
think um
that's the only time
where maybe she was somebody who was
used to being a masculine trying to lead
and she tried to lead in that sense
and that was
that was the only that was the only
efficient way i think a man maybe can
kind of reestablish him himself in that
position if that's where he wants to be